[Music]
stop right there
okay good no signs of overdose no need
for Anna Locke's own Nala what naloxone
it treats opiate overdoses yeah look on
the screen it displaces the opioids that
binds to the opioid receptors in the
central nervous system
weren't you done with using morphine
wait a minute who are you guys don't
worry about us put that down
you've become dependent on opioids what
can I say a little extra medication
never hurt anyone
wrong in 2017 forty-seven thousand
Americans died from opioid overdoses and
1.7 million were abusing prescribed
opiate painkillers
look here see there are two types of
agonist for opiate receptor we have the
endogenous type which are naturally made
within your body and here we have
exogenously Goods which come from nature
and are man-made both types bind to the
receptor is like the capo a bitter
sceptre to relieve pain wait how do I do
this
GPCR opioid receptors are coupled to G
proteins when the G protein is activated
it wonder goes shape change causing
certain activities in the cell to
produce an effect opioids achieve their
effects by preventing near transmitter
release after the opiate binds to the
receptor part of the G protein will bind
with the voltage-gated calcium channel
calcium is important for signaling aka
communication throughout your body
without calcium entering the neuron pain
signal cannot reach its action potential
and pain relief occurs Wow
so that's how these pills work what
happens if I continue taking opioids it
will continue engaging with the Kappa
opiate receptors and can lead to
depression since dopamine levels
decrease in your body
don't worry talking to your doctor can
help you face your addiction
there are also medication assisted
treatment that involve the usage of both
counseling and medicine therapies you
can get through this now drop the
medication
huh where did they go